by show of hands how many people are
voting how many people are excited to
vote for Hillary my name is Darren sands
I'm a reporter with BuzzFeed news based
in Washington DC and I'm cover politics
we're here in Tallahassee Florida
visiting florida A&M university is a
historically black college trying to see
where they are in terms of their
decision-making whether they're going to
vote and try to get a good sense of what
turnout is going to be like becoming a
membrane meet up with right now was one
of clinton's organizers on campus and we
got to see her interact with this young
student a freshman and she was not
actually committed to vote i'm not going
for trunk you can be a leader to say hey
i have a car i'm a freshman as well pack
5 10 people in your car your sin alas
they see you you know the more they're
likely to vote is known as a reminder
like oh that's the voter registration
later you do care you know this is my
university too and i care about the
students as well we get a chance to meet
the up-and-coming mayor of tallahassee a
young black mayor by the name of Andrew
Gilliam and i'll tell you at least on
the social media side you almost don't
have to do a pro Hillary message because
there's so much anti-trump do you think
that affects the enthusiasm that she has
um I'm over the enthusiasm question a
lot of air over I i I'm over it and
where I am is that this is a matter of
our futures and our children's futures
as I have closed out many of remarks to
campuses in to students with elections
or choices that there's some perfect out
there is is not the case I don't believe
Obama
affected but I do believe that his
intentions are consistent with my belief
system and we talked to a lot of older
voters they're black voters people who
went to fam and they recognize you know
the students aren't that excited about
Hillary be honest with you they are
never do I heard I've talked to a lot of
the students who weren't that excited
about Hillary Clinton and even though
they don't know per se like you
Trump scares me I just really was the
kind of Canada's was been stronger on
both sides also at the tailgate we got
the most enormous turkey leg we go to
the president's barbecue and we talked
to about maybe 10 students who acts
table getting ready to work the BBQ
don't you describe the mood of the
student body election candidate like
anything that we do at this point or any
personally and about what exactly their
candy while they're in office and I
don't have faith that whatever anybody
says they're going to do this they will
do honestly I mean I had been akin of it
Bernie Sanders but you know that Kendall
is going there go to Howard Morgan
States but anywhere you went that they
were basically all about burning and
that frustrated a lot of Democrats
because you know Bernie wasn't a
Democrat no we fought for this African
rhythm solving this for decades so it's
the least you could do is vote it's
about you know who were voting for is
going to be
biggest things but just holding them
accountable i think it's going to really
make the most difference i feel like we
can't risk lynnie unbelievable if i
don't go that's me endorsing both Ken
and everything like its entire you I
feel like my vote matters because in all
actuality it does bye-bye so it has how
many people have been canvassed and been
asked if you're building up and run
suitable so they've been canvassing
pretty well I anemic rats are kind of
very anxious that there's going to be a
repeat of two thousand I think the
campaign and also the DNC have taken
that to heart they know that if they
turn out the voters that they need to do
they can win the election so that's what
makes it a turnout election overall we
learned that on this particular campus
no voters are not that excited about
casting a ballot for Hillary Clinton but
they've all been engaged by the campaign
they pretty much all have been asked if
they're registered to vote they're
registered to vote and they're voting
not only do they want to make their
voices heard but they also want to make
sure that she can be held accountable
for changes that can be made with racial
injustice and that they don't want to
actually disrespect the idea that
people fought for the right to vote they
died for the right to vote they
protested blood was shed and at fam
that's something that people don't take
lightly
[Music]